le monde cessent pas et aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur un jeu d'horreur qui
date de plusieurs années mais qui est
extrêmement incroyable john the grudge
ça fait deux heures que je vous dis que
doit tomber cette vidéo et que je fais
pas le courage de le faire
un moment fou ya les oublie pas c'est
parti sélectionnez votre sexe je suis un
homme un jour d'y mettre une femme telle
que est un peu moins de scream heures et
toutes ces conneries attend ce chien
déjà fait un bruit avec le bruit de ce
chien me fait peur pour s'inscrire à
mertzen aux [ __ ] à sanaa ok est
l'endroit le plus stylé du monde alors
on arrive aux mondiaux des pieds mon
dieu oh le cheikh lui faire une pédicure
ça y est je sur des conneries pour
assurer le suivi
elle s'est enfuie je me demande ce
qu'elle a pu voir on dirait que cette
usine n'a pas été utilisé depuis un
siècle
mais comme je suis conne et moche je
vais rentrer dedans bon il n'a pas l'air
de vouloir revenir je vais aller la
chercher
pourquoi tu veux pas juste une gamelle
rempli de croquettes devant la porte par
laquelle la chaîne est rentré et attend
d'ailleurs à côté en train de lire un
naruto enfin je celle là un monsieur qui
se faisait que ça oh là là ce sont les
endroits mediaglow code hays a le petit
bruit des vues et petits with the grudge
pour ceux qui ont plus de grade à la
porte qui soit c'est quoi ces des
cheveux à travers ce que peuvent
s'amuser avec ses cheveux dans un trou
c'est parti nous sommes dans l'ambiance
petite chienne un truc qui brille là-bas
attendait parce que un bon je pense que
déjà c'est une porte ouverte ce n'est
pas le chien
le pacs et mons quoi j'ai pas que moi
bien là allez viens à l'essai suffit les
conneries fond du jeu allez qu'est ce
que c'est que ça mais va la prendre cool
à va la prendre mon gars wahou un enfant
nu quoi ok ça marche bon alors [ __ ] le
média là tu parles en courant de lusine
quoi [ __ ] temps faute aux chiens
bordel la technique croquettes bien oui
ok je me casse je prends des trucs qui
brille pas ce que ça doit sûrement être
très très utile marche carrément à deux
à l'heure ce parti on a pris une pile
effectivement en bas à gauche on a eu la
batterie est ce que vous pouvez
retourner à lait du mois couple y
retourner allez bon à 8h le cul du chien
m'a fait peur quoi sans déconner à temps
si je peux y aller francs c'est fermé
mais via mais pourquoi tu veux te friter
avec un petit garçon tout nu toi viens
[ __ ] de chiens ah bah voilà le truc
qui brille yes c'est une mine victoire
ok on a eu la clé du zen
alors je suppose que c'est la clé de la
porte qui ferme et là que le petit
garçon a fermé un [ __ ] de petites
actions toujours détesté pour
qui fait ça c'est l'autre qui vérifier
si la porte est bien fermée oui elle va
fermer plus tard j'ai la clé mon gars au
cas tous les coups je vous la porte il
plus là attention devant pas de vin au
[ __ ] c'est horrible communes ouvertes
wart et pim de bach à temps mais à
chaque fois qu'il va ouvrir une porte ou
sept comme ça c'est horrible quoi tu as
sans déconner mais ma caméra elle a
lâché au moment où il ya eu çà quand
elle a arrêté de filmer l affaire je
peux plus moi non plus ok on ouvre on y
va à temps mais n'y avait pas deux fois
de suite quand même quoi ou alors faut
changer de porte je ne sais pas assez
horrible
ok c'est bon on est passé près des
sortes de trucs blanqui au hockey ça va
qu'est-ce qu'elle regarde y'a rien n'y a
rien arrête de vouloir me faire peur ça
marche pas ça marche pas tu as raté
battant mais surtout chaud dans le jeu
sans déconner tu as un peu mon temps sur
ces palettes et dansons et dégageant et
[ __ ] j'essaie de me rassurer comme je
peux mais je trouve même plus puisqu'il
faut dire pour rassurer à temps a pas
mal ok donc pour faire demi-tour fenêtre
mais fait quoi lui sans déconner [ __ ]
taille ces clauses d'une fête foraine je
suis là quand on avait un pistolet il
fallait tirer et sites sur lui et qu'il
apparaît sais quoi mais non ok ça
commence très mal cette vidéo n'est pas
d'hier alors pour vous ça doit commencer
bien bien sûr [ __ ] de sadiq nom mais
par contre cette vitesse de marche et
scandaleuse quoi on va faire une
pétition pour qu'elle marche plus vite
cette femme serveuse on attend je veux
bien croire que tu as peur ma ce moment
là tu rentres pas dans les usines ou une
clé hockey à tous restera à voir des
points en route tomber peut-être thomas
depuis n'importe quoi des croquettes
pour chien
on a la clé de l'entrepôt mais encore
faut-il trouver la porte de l'entrepôt
qui a fait exprès de mettre là est déjà
sur un grand écran
bravo encore plus de sensations elle ne
s'est pas des sensations c'est de la
torture d'un film bien là bas oui ça
fumait bien j'aurais préféré que ça ne
fait même pas que j'étais chaud c'est
une vidéo sur l est et au bizet
disneyland
mais c'est quoi ce bruit temps mais
yahia le vent de quelqu'un qui
gargouille non jeu ça c'est clair et net
ouvre la porte à la clé oh non non non
non non oui on est passé on avance on
avance on avance allait ouvre la porte
elle est fermée elle fermait ont la
force la force
non ok je ratais de faire le coup
puisque je perds du temps de piles et
peut-être quelque chose de caché sous
ses marches à awala on a bien fait
d'aller par là
prenons donc c'est une pile du magazine
qu'il y ait une pile on a pas on n'a pas
vu le truc là qui brillent comme on l'a
fait et c'est la fin du marathon
d'affaires le plan du monde c'est
incroyable
encore une pile [ __ ] d trop bien là
alors en attendant les marges sa vitesse
va être par contre vraiment lente
suppose aulas mais c'est une catastrophe
au non jamais vu ce à quoi même en est
qui marche sur les mains en équilibre va
public quel qu'il soit dans ce couloir
est ce qu'on peut retrouver ce [ __ ] de
chef barry un jour 1 ça serait vraiment
une bonne idée alors sachez pas ce que
c'est mais croyez-moi je vais pas
rentrer une cavité cassé je préfère
rocher continuons ok c'est bon on oui
mon gars d'ascenseur et un truc qui
brille par terre ce que c'est que ça que
c'est que ça qui fait qu'il imite un
chat là ok on est quoi la clé de la
salle d'examens ou et la salle d'examen
puis-je prendre l'ascenseur pour me
parler d'ici aller sur le toit et barioz
en hélico en faisant non c'est
impossible
attention le screamer au retour au nom
mais là va y avoir un truc c'est sûr et
certain
c'est assez à gauche la salle d'examen
nager crois pas [ __ ] y'a pas de
poignée déjà à partir de cesser sa place
est de je me casse
c'est bon c'est le truc des adacore bat
déjà il manque le quelqu'un coupe
l'électricité d'accord apparemment il
n'avait pas trop envie que je prenne
l'ascenseur je vois pourquoi bon par la
limite j'aurais invités avec moi dans
l'hélico à faire des témoins
vous pensez qu'il faut que j'aille voir
le plan des électriques donc si mes
calculs sont bons la personne qui a
racheté ce panneau avait neuf voir ça
marche est ce qu'on peut
non il n'y a rien à faire j'ai pas
remonte les plombs moi j'y crois
toujours
où est la salle d'examen abbas et ça
bien sûr que c'est ça la salle d'examen
à montluc a bien sûr et là tu parles à
toi-même donc été légèrement
schizophrène dans le cas salles d'examen
hockey au [ __ ] je trie pas assez sûr
c'est sûr qu'une petite cinématique
comme ça je ok c'est bon alors l'étape
hockey ou au plus tard puisque quand je
fais des gros mouvements la porte est
faible alors même si un truc qui brille
oui ils sont mes seuls amis dont je te
sont souvent des piles 1 qu'est ce qui a
fait rire parce que chez sous le bureau
en position foetale pas grand chose à
nous sommes dans la salle d'examen
y'a pas un truc sur le bureau la droite
bien sûr que sumo le cas elles sont
perdues quoi il ya des herbes un choix
que j'ai atteint ce qu'ils meurent sans
faire exprès mais j'ai raté un screamer
et ça me plaît beaucoup
ça me plaît beaucoup vraiment ça me
plaît beaucoup bon je disais les apps
ont perdu en chemin elles sont leurs
spots c'est que ça un peigne un hunter
un pour l'ascenseur mon gars je suis sûr
qu'ils étaient là screamer par ici comme
ça hein et on va pas trop l'énerver
il a fait son truc qu'on laisse
s'installer tranquillement rentrer à la
maison
bourita femme a avec les violons et tous
là je suis prêt à ce que je suis pas
secouer
oui c'est bon tu sais que sorte allô oui
maman a dû sauver
je m'appelle à monsieur vous avez un
problème à la gorge
elle a mon numéro ok donc l'autre m'a
appelé et a fait son petit son petit one
man show au téléphone un an privé pour
moi et elle m'a fait payer soit on pense
à aulas faut remonter à l'est on se
retrouve dans 22 minutes aller chercher
à manger de voir votre écran et on
dégage au mais non mais ces
interrupteurs du panneau électrique en
bas ça hein mais l'udc avec qui tu nous
as fait ah ah bah voilà c'est bien ça
que je disais j'espère retourner aux
yeux ouverts carrément oh [ __ ] ça
pulse kemmer ça c'est pas moi qui ai la
main oui allô mon dieu qu'est-ce qui a
fait que son coût est non plus abbas est
passé alors celle qu'on aide à un mois
oui tu tu sois accrochée au plafond la
commune via régner moi je veux reprendre
l'ascenseur aux gars y'a pas moyen
c'est ça qu'il fallait faire ou pas à
mon avis pas du tout oui
yes sac fallait faire mon gars
voilà enfin du jeu mon gars fin du jeu
oui tiens t'es croquettes
qu'est-ce qu'il fait montre ses fesses
c'est pour ça que j'ai envie la séance
se crashe wii reste avec moi je tiens
reste avec moi c'est le vol de chiens on
est vraiment dans la merde
il va partir en course à s'ouvrir non
c'est pas ça
bah ça [ __ ] ça donne une paire une
teisseire mais mon gâteau
et voilà moi un chien épisodes terminés
tous ceux qui entrent sur condamné une
nouvelle forme de malédiction est né
quelle tristesse vous devriez essayer
d'utiliser votre charme du verso pour
rendre votre lâcheté attirante sapin
mois de juin jeux vidéo et que le jeu
vidéo m'insulte quoi c'est quoi ça après
l' usine désaffectée seller de l'hôpital
abandonné oh [ __ ] l'hôpital mon gars
ça c'est ça ce je me sens pas ça ouais
on entend longtemps un enfant courir
dans couloir
oui oui habille toi c'est mieux
paraît-il c'est en fait c'est nous le
monstre du jeu sinon voilà harmonieux
patients dit dans les couloirs des
autres bateaux à la lampe torche quand
même c'est quoi ce boucan assez bien un
jeu qui date de quatre ans à pourquoi
personne ne répond ça doit être un
enfant qui court
mais que font les infirmières je vais
les voir ce qui se passe belle sinon
d'or et laisse les infirmières faire le
travail
aum à tort il fait quoi il fait un
concert privé lui aussi après le one man
show ces le concert c'est ça y'a rien au
piège chez le petit enfant tu sais qui
est celui qui se croit la fête foraine
c'est pas très grave si c'est grave
alors et point ce téléphone est plus que
ça puisque cette sonnerie commence à
être insupportable alors je suppose que
je dois aller à la chambre aïe j'ai un
plan bon là ça peut pas être plus clair
301 ils demandent de l'aide et moi c'est
quoi un chant de là haut
arrête si on se situe ses numéros de la
chambre bon ben alors arrête on peut
entrer l'un je veux une pile non
qu'est-ce qu'il ya ici mais y'a rien
témoigne avait annoncé un pied de vie
j'ai cru que c'est des pieds de petit
enfant que celle du 32 et je sais pas
mal à ce que c'était vraiment une bonne
idée
non à ça pour avoir des télés manger des
chips de match de foot ça y va par
contre par l'un des plus d'un pilon
c'est un monomoteur
c'est un truc pour désinfecter les mains
mais c'est pas un extincteur qu'ils ont
quatre courses et une lampe torche quoi
tout le monde sait que l'hôpital est
finalement car mentionnant à 320 il ya
un truc mais y'a ghetto c'est sûr et
certain
aya étoiles est celle ci qu'est ce
qu'ils voulaient que je fasse de cette
[ __ ] de chien rien et que moi dans cet
hôpital en fait je suis le seul
il ya de plus affirmé à l'ap le pitch
aux gens non voilà j'utilise on dit bon
on n'a plus de budget pour lui va
arriver dans son hôpital mais gaillette
est terminée alors est ce que c'est un
une indication disant que je dois aller
aux toilettes masculine où est ce que je
me barre d'ici qui comprend la torche et
on passe pas ses sketches courts ça me
paraît être le meilleur truc à faire au
monde
tatataaa allez passons par là bien bien
sûr bien sûr la sortie est fermé mais
calmes et lucas à gauche là ce qu'on
peut y aller dit tu vois que oui mais il
aime trop les toiles et donc je dors à
mais c'est à animations la caméra s'est
éteinte en plus haut je te laisse te
lâche de la ciat potes là ok gauche
droite gauche droite gauche droite
gauche comme moi assez bon je suis un
peu enflammé à temps elle faisait quoi
toilettes quoi [ __ ] elle publie ces
dames poker dont elles sont ballester
que c'est un fantôme bordel obligé
d'aller aux toilettes
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de l'uriné magique de
fantômes n'y en a pas bon banc des non
alliés du vécu ici a noté il ya du pq de
recul à paris xi est bon voilà mais
alors avec quoi donc s'est essuyé le
fantôme vite je pense des délires de
merde sans déconner j'ai tellement
tellement peur à ce qu'elle est du coup
l auto les défis liés à tanger tétouan
des filles ce qui est un peu c'est un
peu normal qui avait agressé du coup
tout prend son spectacle ici il y aura
peut-être une pile on sait jamais une
pile de secours aussi aux toilettes ça
arrive vous avez vu ça il ya des [ __ ]
de cheveux par terre mon gars alors sois
quelqu'un sait vraiment pas raser les
jambes soit à la femme est là dedans
oh c'est mort elle est là regardez ces
on l'entend banon elle a juste récupérer
ces boîtes de gens s'appuient streamer
assez fermé bon au moins on sait qu'elle
est là quoi le nom du niveau c'est
hôpital abandonné il ya pas de problème
alors qu'est ce que je foutais
hospitalisés dans cet hôpital s'il a
abandonné [ __ ] kim swan a envoyé le
tri désinfectant dont je vous parlais
voilà et si en fait fallait peut-être
dans la chambre 300 une et alumine télé
j'ai pas je m'en bas si vous faire alors
ça se trouve sur des théories de merde à
la caf est licite
mais allez donc totale mais toutes les
télés et à la télé ah ouais [ __ ] à
effet sable à gramat ça se trouve ils me
laissaient de m'indiquer quelque chose
en moi et moi je lui crache dessus comme
un bâtard et les trucs par terre qu'est
ce que c'est c'est peut-être le pq de
l'autre finalement voilà elle est passée
par là elle a dit brawn gp j'ai oublié
le juge et clame une couleur on va
retourner à la 300 une voyez toutes les
télés ça va invoquer la puissance divine
et superman qui va nous aider et nous
sauver à un niveau batterie on est
vraiment vraiment vraiment dans la merde
c'est fini les piles avec la lumière de
la télé on sait qu'avec la télé
maintenant
non non non non allez allez on peut dit
nous qu'on continue c'est quoi ce bordel
où l'attend aux ânes ont annoncé film
c'est fini le cas c'est fini c'est fini
le cas c'est fini fin afin de na pas
avoir là c'est fini
en tout cas je perds c'est vous aura plu
c'est qu'elles n'étaient pas élèves ne
savent pas vraiment plaisir
et puis hop attend une traite de la shdm
et c'est quoi ça m'était foncier
mouillart